well we start with the heatwave that
continues to batter India extreme
temperatures across the north and the
east of the country have caused hundreds
of deaths in the south the searing hot
spell has led to severe water shortages
the situation has reached a crisis point
in Chennai this is India's sixth biggest
city Chennai's four main water
reservoirs have dried up take a look at
the satellite image from one year ago
you can see the water levels there and
this is what it looks like now residents
are desperate for rain but monsoon
season and Tamil Nadu isn't supposed to
come until late in the fall locals are
now blaming authorities for failing to
recognize the shortage and deal with it
early on
[Music]
Barun and almost born dry this reservoir
is down to its last 1% of water a
shepherd has led his animals to the last
few drops
[Music]
this is what Red Hills Lake should look
like but now an acute drought has
crippled Chennai's water supply
after months of high temperatures and
extreme water scarcity experts say the
situation is grave for last two years
there's a deficit in the rainfall that
is one thing the second thing is channa
always goes through the cycle of for
five to ten years we have the cycle
where the rainfall actually fails the
city the city turned off the Hasan
family's water more than 40 days ago
since then they've had to buy drinking
water they still get enough from the tap
thanks to their underground tanks the
systems collect and creat rain water
during the monsoon season
this way they can survive dry spells but
now their reserves are running out water
tax okay every month I guess Potiphar
taxes and like I told you last month
what happened to my tax that I paid okay
I did not get even a drop of water so
that is one where the government has not
stood up to its responsibilities after
Chennai shut off its water supply the
city turned to sending tanker trucks
into desperate villages to fill them
attacked groundwater wells tanker
drivers also deliver waters from other
regions throughout the country people
are suffering a lot from the scarcity
and heavy demand for water we've had
more than 500 bookings to deliver water
only the pure neighbourhoods are
provided with free water though not
every day
deliveries often come with drama the
mood among the locals is tense it's not
long before the situation escalates
[Laughter]
[Music]
we get water through that pump but it is
sewage water and has a foul smell they
will tell us to use that water for daily
needs at the other end of the same
street people get water delivered by
water tanks every day but we don't get
it
residents here have had to pay water tax
for the past two years know they're
demanding clean water supplies to fill
up their own reserve tanks in recent
times Chennai has become one of India's
key industrial engines during the
building boom the city paved over
natural water sources the state Supreme
Court has told Chennai to stop this but
little has been done several rivers flow
through Chennai one is being widened to
create another lane for river traffic
the water quality is miserable
this river like many here more like open
sewers so this government is talking
about early reusing the sewage treating
it to a to an acceptable standard which
can be used by the industry so that
there they are trying to eliminate
industry as a major user of pure fresh
groundwater outside Chennai the result
of industry's appetite for fresh water
is laid bare the water table has fallen
dramatically on top of that the farmers
grow rice and sugarcane both Devourer
water the women say their husbands are
forced to seek work in the cities to
support their families
[Music]
if it had rained it would have been
better for the crops and for us but
there's no water even to drink The
Situation's disastrous back at the Red
Hills Lake Reservoir drought conditions
make renovations easier the first
upgrade since it was built in 1910 by
British engineers the region has long
struggled with periods of drought the
state government plans to invest 33
million euros in the water supply
but Chennai is holding out for the
monsoon though only mild rains are
forecast not nearly enough to quench the
thirst and we can get the latest on the
story GWS bearish Banerjee is standing
by in Delhi monitoring the situation in
Chennai for a Siberia she's good to see
you we heard the accusation in our
report from locals that authorities did
not do enough to get ahead of the
situation is that a fair accusation hi
for me to a great extent yes I would say
and that's what a number of experts are
saying as well now you must bear in mind
that Chennai which is the capital of the
state of Tamil Nadu along with Tamil
Nadu gets rains from what's called the
Northeast monsoons now these happen
between the months of October and
December now as far back as January it
became clear that these monsoons were a
failure in many ways which is to say
that the state of Tamil Nadu and hence
Chennai by extension did not get the
amount of rainfall that was expected
this rainfall is important to fill the
reservoirs that feed chand I am you saw
a glimpse of those reservoirs which had
completely dried up in that report that
you just add now the state government
knew about this in January they
instituted a bit of water rationing but
that's about it
so you basically had a situation in
which Chennai was heading to an acute
water shortage in the summer months and
a state government that really wasn't
prepared but beyond this to me what is
really important to look at is beyond
the current administration and the
current government it has literally been
a failure of successive governments and
successive administrations in Chennai to
stop the massive spread of urbanization
Chennai is a fairly green city it has
three rivers it has four as was it has
five
wetlands six forests most of these are
aligned polluted and not usable a lot of
them have dried up it's literally been
pure poor water management to blame over
successive years a lot of this
urbanization as well that I mentioned
has been happening on the banks of the
rivers it has been happening on lake
beds so a lot of these water resources
have been depleted without any alternate
to replace them so the situation is bad
bearish you're saying and it looks like
it's only going to get worse what can be
done at this point other than waiting
for rain well at the moment Jena is
doing what it can do best which is look
at short-term solutions in which they
are trying to buff up the resources that
are available to the city and by that I
mean looking at the three major
desalinization plants that provide water
to the city they're working at nearly
maximum capacity to achieve maximum
efficiency other than that the number of
tankers that are being made available in
the city has gone up there are proposals
there are talks to bring in piped water
from more than 200 kilometres away and
there is also a talk of sending in water
through through railway wagons into the
city that's the short-term nature of it
but of course that throws open the
longer-term question as to what is
generalized long term strategy to manage
these situations in the future and that
is where experts are cautioning that
things like rainwater harvesting need to
be implemented in full so that the city
has water as it was to tide over these
kinds of periods and there is also an
appeal being made to the city's
residents to perhaps change their water
consumption habits because clearly
Chennai doesn't have so much water that
it can literally waste or call upon when
needed
DW spirit energy reporting in Delhi
forests thank you very much